[Music]
let's go to ray in
raleigh north carolina beautiful part of
the country what's up ray
uh hey how you doing we're getting it
how about you i'm doing pretty good how
about uh how about yourself yeah well uh
we're all right we're all right if i
told you that today was just the
greatest that would be dishonest but you
know what we're doing well the
heater and air conditioning works and my
paycheck deposited so i i'm gonna count
it good we're gonna go from there
okay sounds good so what's up
well um me and my husband have suffered
some pretty big tree trauma growing up
and are still going through some stuff
now
yeah i need to know how to deal with it
oh hon
you said big t trauma right
yeah
so that's it's still sitting on you
pretty tight because it's hard to even
say it out loud tell me what's going on
okay
take your breath take your time
okay so um
my mom was killed when i was little oh
man
and um
i was
messed with
when i was growing up
and
my parents
my stepmom and my dad were pretty
emotionally abusive
and
they they became alcoholics
whenever i turned 18
i think they may have suffered that um
whenever i was growing up but i never
noticed it until i turned 18.
um
they always just kind of i was just kind
of secluded and left to myself for the
most part
did they know about the sexual abuse
no i've never told anyone except my
husband and my best friend gotcha okay
um
and my husband
he was um raped when he was 10 by a
close family friend and
his mom was pretty sexually abusive
towards him
and um
his i mean pretty much her whole family
were pretty emotionally abusive to us
but we have like no one
and the one person we thought we had
this year to help us out was um
our grandma and his side and it turned
out that she was just using us
so that she can regain her relationship
with her
son which is my husband's dad and um
everything that we were telling her and
trying to confide in her
she was just relaying back to that to
the people that have abused us
and i've i've got three awesome
beautiful girls and an awesome husband
and
you know we've been through a lot
and it's like every pregnancy i've had
it's like they've reared their ugly
heads and showed up yes
and um we we sent
them letters both both as a parent um
with my parents i just told them you
know
we i've already called them and asked
them hey don't drink around the kids you
know
i know you've got an alcohol problem and
i'm i don't judge you for drinking we
don't care about that at all i just
don't want you doing it when the kids
are there
and my stepmom has ended up calling my
husband or not calling she facebooked my
husband's mom and was like playing that
man in a booboo i get to see the
grandkids and you don't card to her
so all that was screenshot by his dad
and sent to him
are you on your cell phone
yes okay
um
take your phone and i'll just wait here
for a second and i want you to pull up
your parents
and i want you to
delete their numbers from your phone
okay
or block them i don't know the right way
to do that i just know they need to be
out where they can't contact they're
you're done
okay well i've already blocked them on
facebook and
just yeah
done
okay
and then i want you to take your in-laws
and done they're blocked they can't
contact you they can't get in touch with
you they're not welcome around you
they're not welcome around your family
yeah so that
and
okay they're done
done yes
yeah
no more no more discussions no more
trying to make this thing work no more
being responsible for
their brutality and their evil
and their manipulation and their abuse
and their silence
no more yeah you got three little girls
that are worth more than that
you and your husband have found yourself
on the other side of hell but you you're
still chained to it and you're going to
find out those chains aren't
clasped you're holding on to those
chains i want you to let them go
okay and that's hard
but we're done
[Music]
okay
well see that that's the problem i'm
having me and my husband are a little
out of disconnect with that okay that's
fine um that's fine uh here here's
here's what here's the the things you
just laid out to me i bet your aces
score is a seven or eight if not
more
uh i want you to get online today and
aces a-c-e-s it's the adverse childhood
experiences scale
um i want you to just take it it's
online it's ten questions
and
if you score over a four which you have
you're more likely to get cancer strokes
heart attacks all
your body is at war
yes right yeah yep and
the goal of healing from big t trauma is
this trauma simply means your body is
responding in the present to things that
happen in the past as though it's
happening again right now
yeah
and if you were sexually abused as a
child as you have daughters that get
within shouting distance of that age
your body remembers that story
yes and it starts sounding every alarm
because it's danger danger danger
yep and
it's not a matter if you don't trust
them it's that your body doesn't trust
the world and more importantly your body
doesn't trust relationships
and that's that weird thing is you gotta
you gotta have relationships or we die
literally exactly yeah i finally was
able to make one
awesome friend um i worked with her and
i've got one we've got one person in our
life that we can trust awesome awesome
so
the goal is is to
work through the big t trauma so that
you can think about what happened
you can remember those conversations
a on your own terms and b your body
doesn't take off on you because it knows
it's safe now
that's the goal right right you can't
undo that stuff we got to own it it
happened and then the question is now
what right
um yes
first
the first thing the first order of
business is cutting ties with the people
who abuse you
yes
and your language in this case matters
um
how did you how did your mom how was she
killed
an ex-boyfriend
shot her at a gas station okay so
they're killed is
is me the word is your mom passed away
she died
but yes the way you told that to me
could have been a car wreck
could have been a medical issue your mom
was murdered
yes and you have to own that language
you were not messed with as a kid
you were sexually abused
yeah
and when you come up with in this and i
do it we all do it
when we use language to take the sting
off of what happened to us in our
present in our past
some you know sometimes people say like
well my husband just was you know
uh he cheated on you right you got to
say it out loud
yeah your body feels the weight of it
but your mind has new words
and you know what happens when you lay
old new flooring over old flooring and
there's water there mold grows
underneath it just rots out everything
yeah and so we got to use the words of
what actually happened
and then we have to respond to that
stuff okay
yeah your parents were
abusive they were alcoholic they were
absent
trauma can also be so you told me some
big t traumas you you probably know this
big t trauma can also be what didn't
happen
yeah moms and dads are supposed to be
present with their kids and let them
know that they're safe and that they are
loved
and yeah children of alcoholics don't
get that
that's correct right
so
the goal here is to experience
those to think about those things and
your body doesn't take off on you you're
able to just be present with your
husband with your daughters sounds like
your husband still wants to stay
connected to them
yeah okay um he well he wants
he wants to separate us from it but he
thinks that he can be this big wall that
separates but i don't want him to be the
wall because it's just like letting the
stupid bear in the living room maul my
husband so that he doesn't get to us i
think there needs to be a separation
from all of it absolutely yes so
your husband is trying to be a good kid
and as somebody who grew up like he did
he was probably responsible
for the
emotional and psychological and
relational well-being of the adults in
his life
well can i tell you what happened this
weekend absolutely yeah
is
we told them in a letter that we were
not talking to his mother period and we
were having no contact with her and we
were just completely and totally done
with her and we needed to go seek
counsel on how to handle his dad because
that's where we weren't
agreeing on how to handle it i just
wanted to cut him off just like his mom
um
and he doesn't see it that way yet
because he was closer to his dad in his
eyes than anyone else well anyway
his dad called him the other day or
messaged him and said that he wanted to
meet with a man to man like degrading my
husband
okay i don't know that's what it sounded
like to me but anyway he met with him at
a park and he brought his favorite
freaking cookies that his mom gave him
um
it's like i guess a peace offering or
whatever and tried to talk things or he
wanted to talk things out but my husband
wasn't giving him any information or
anything just
that we weren't going to be talking to
mom pretty much and um
his dad told him he he asked him you
know if the stuff that your mom did
bothered you why didn't you say anything
about it and it made me stick and oh
yeah
don't that crap because now oh it's your
husband's fault now
yeah exactly
stupid you know whose fault it is
i'm gonna go down that road here's the
deal
dad knew that crap was going on
yes absolutely
and it's not just the dad the grandma
has
she called the hospital when i was
giving birth to my third daughter in uh
september
she showed up to our house the week
after i had my baby
not invited unannounced my oldest
daughter was crying because she couldn't
understand why she couldn't go see
grandma
and i had to explain to her honey we're
not talking to grandma right now i don't
know how to explain this to you right
now but when i know i will tell you one
day not right now
and
then my husband got her to leave and
then she told him that she was going to
call his dad and then showed up the next
day uninvited luckily this time i saw
them so i was able to get the kids in
the back room so that my husband could
go handle them outside
but they showed up with his mom his dad
and his grandma they all came back and
um
i just want to call the cops absolutely
have them deal with them absolutely this
is manipulative
narcissist nonsense
exactly and his his grandma showed up at
his place of work last night
and um
yeah so grandma needs to be notified
that there's going to be a restraining
order against her if she shows up again
okay
okay should we even have a talk with her
because i don't think we should at this
point i
at some point surely your husband has
said you're not welcome here i'd like
you to go
well he did at the at the um whenever
she showed up at our house but now he
we agreed that we would have a
conversation with her but i don't even
think there needs to be a conversation
anymore i would not have one in person i
would make a phone call i would okay and
i would say
you are not welcome in my house you are
no longer a part of our life
i would recommend and ray and i know
this is hard i'd recommend y'all think
about what the next 18 months 12 months
24 months looks like for you all to move
and go somewhere these these roads haunt
you
yes i want i've been wanting to move so
bad it's time it's time and here's
here's the thing
it's time for you to sit down and tell
your husband what's actually happening
and here's what i you can tell me i'm
wrong
but children who grew up in systems of
abuse which is how you grew up and your
husband did too
they get really good at two things
making sure everybody around them is
okay
and keeping secrets
yup and you all have an ecosystem in
your home where both of you are trying
to make sure the other one's okay
you're trying to keep up a fantasy where
these kids that you have these beautiful
daughters that you have are still gonna
have grandparents
and y'all keep secrets from each other
well not really um
we
we tell each other everything even when
it hurts does he know
that you're about done
because you are absolutely okay
he gets it yes
yes all right so here's supported me
calling today i think he just needs to
hear it from somebody else good because
he's about to lose you
yeah
yeah i'm getting pretty resentful yes
there you go and he may not lose you in
spirit i mean a body but he's going to
lose you in spirit
yeah and then you know what happens this
whole cycle starts over again
yeah
because the only way to get over the gap
of being married to someone who you love
but you chose abusers over them the only
way to get through that is disconnecting
whether it's alcohol or whether it's
working too much or whether it's
somebody what
here it goes again and your daughters
grow up in a house with two people who
are absent and
they're there in body but they're not
there in spirit and the whole thing
happens again
yep
right you and your husband are doing
brave things you're still like terry
reel says you're staring down this
forest fire
and saying the generational trauma stops
with us
yep but what i'm telling you is you
gotta go all the way
okay you can't stare this forest fire
down and one of you's got a hose and the
other person is just being like hey
don't spray so hard don't spray that
water too fast you're gonna then you're
gonna both you're everybody's gonna burn
how
like
i i just made a friend
and i'm afraid i'll lose her if i move
you
listen
right now you're s
let's worry about things in order okay
okay let's worry about things in order
you might have a different relationship
you might have to go make new friends
here's what you've proven to yourself
that you're worth being loved and you're
worth hanging out with
yeah and you're worth having joy and
there are good people a whole whole
bunch of them that are trustworthy that
you can tell crazy things too and then
we'll laugh and say hey i'll buy beers
or you found that person it exists
yeah and so i want you to know that
there's a bunch of hers out there
now am i telling you you got to break up
with your friend and all that kind of
stuff but i'm telling you this first you
got to get safe and you're not safe
yes
first second you got to get on the same
page with your husband
you all got to get on the same page with
a game plan
and at some point it comes to you saying
we are moving you can be a part of this
conversation but i can't be around this
evil any more
okay
the fantasy that you're gonna hold this
family together that grandparents are
gonna come around it's over
all right
and you've if you've ever listened we've
done over 200 something shows of this
show i've never watched all of them
you're the only one i i've never told
somebody
to get their phone out and disconnect
from their parents forever and i'm
telling you that
right right because they've got their
foot on your head and you underwater and
you can't breathe
and it's time yes
it's time
okay
let that
go yeah that feels really good to hear
you and your husband i want you to go
meet with somebody together if you can
okay if you can't afford it sell
something
i'd rather you sit on folding lawn
chairs in your living room then have a
couch but make sure that you and your
husband have gotten six sessions of
trauma counseling together cause y'all
got a lot of healing and you don't want
to pass this on
right i mean we've yeah so here's what i
i don't know if y'all have done this
maybe you have maybe you haven't i want
you guys
you've heard me say this a thousand
times and you're getting it too have you
ever gone to
somewhere and just said what could it be
like
usually in people in your position
you're trying to always putting out the
next fire the next fire in the next fire
you never get to sit down and dream what
would it look like there was just no
fires
well actually we we started this whole
healing process like five years ago when
we started like watching the dave ramsey
stuff and we just got out of debt and
paid off our house at the beginning of
this year wow
congrats
thank you i appreciate that
everybody that's when we started
noticing the or i guess figuring out
that our family were not going to be
able to be a part of their lives yes
once they saw that we were doing better
it brings the leeches out yes yes
the vampires come out so
you may have to sell that paid for house
and go pay for another house with cash
in another city
yeah
yeah i know it's hard i know it's hard
but you live around vampires and at some
point they're gonna one of them is gonna
get their teeth in your kids
exactly yeah that's the scary part one
of their kids cousins sisters roommates
brother is going to be it's just going
to go on and on and on
here let's do this in order though
moving is not a conversation for today
conversation for today is we start
by getting evil out of my house
i will not allow people to abuse me or
my family or manipulate us anymore start
with a phone call to all appearance to
grandma this is the last phone call we
are disconnecting from you
if you come to our house unannounced we
will call the police
if you show up to my kid's school we
will call the police
we are
done
and that will be hard and you'll have to
grieve that with your husband that'll be
hard and then you begin making plans for
what is next
but you're worth a life where you're not
abused anymore
you're worth a life where your daughters
are safe
and you're worth a life of laughter
and joy and really hard work
in the gym at your career
at whatever your hobbies are
you're with more i'm sorry that this
these the cards you were dealt right
you've played them incredibly you have
played them in
credibly
and now it's time to get up from that
table and go to another table
you outgrown that table
you're an absolute brave rock star
keep us in the loop over the next few
months and we'll walk alongside you it's
grateful i'm grateful to have gotten to
talk to you today you're a brave brave
soul